[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركه
احييكم
وانا عربيه 360 الخبر من كل سواء ومن جميع
جوانبه
بكين تعتبر مساله تايوان تهديد الابرز
للعلاقات مع واشنطن وتؤكد التزامها بناء
علاقات مستقره معها
[موسيقى]
اوكرانيا تساعد هجماتها على مخازن الاسلحه
الروسيه
وتكتيكات روسيه جديده على جبهات القتال
اسرائيل تشترط لتطوير حقل غاز قباله سواحل
غزه ضمانات امنيه من السلطه الفلسطينيه
ومصر
وتتابعون معنا الليله ايضا
نجلب بايدن هانتر مهدد بالسجن قبل سباق
الانتخابات الرئاسيه الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
اذا نقاط اتفاق وملفات شائكه طبعت زياره
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه للعاصمه الصينيه
للقاء نظيره وزير الخارجيه الصينيه
اكد ان ملف تايوان هو التهديد ابرز
للعلاقات مع الولايات المتحده واعتبر
الوزير ان القضيه قضيه هي جوهر المصالح
الصينيه ونقل لنظيره مخاوف بشان مصالحها
هناك في جانب اخر راويه اكد وزير الخارجيه
الصيني لنظيره الامريكي وزير الخارجيه
انطوني بلينكن اكد استعداد والتزام بكين
لبناء علاقات مستقره مع واشنطن وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه
اكد ضروره ابقاء قنوات الاتصال مفتوحه بين
الدولتين لتجنب اي سوء فهم واعتبر بلينكن
الزياره خطوه اولى لكنه شدد على استحاله
حل المشاكل مع الصين بزياره واحده بعدما
بحث مع نظيره الخلافات بين البلدين وفرص
عوده التعاون كما اكد بلنكن على وجود
توافق بين واشنطن للعمل سويا من اجل
التقدم في علاقات الدولتين
من بينها زياده عدد الرحلات الجويه
التجاريه بين البلدين اضافه لزياده عدد
الطلاب وزيارات رجال الاعمال بين البلدين
خلال الاجتماع وجه وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
لنظيره الصيني دعوه لزياره واشنطن وقال
انه سيقوم بالزياره في الوقت المناسب
سفينه حربيه صينيه تقترب من مدمره امريكيه
في مضيق تايوان وفي السماء مقاتله صينيه
تعترض طائره امريكيه فوق بحر الصين
الجنوبي حوادث يمكن ان تتحول الى مواجهه
عسكريه بين قطبي الشرق والغرب
لمنع هذا الاحتمال وصل وزير الخارجيه
بلينكن الى بكين
سوف نعبر عن مخاوفنا بشان تصرفات الصين في
عدد من المجالات خلال الزياره اعتقد ان
المجالات التي لدينا مخاوف حيالها معروفه
جدا الفنتانيل قضايا مضيق تايوان والوقوف
مع روسيا في حربها في اوكرانيا ومجموعه من
القضايا الاخرى
في خاصره الصين الجنوبيه مناوره عسكريه
بين الفلبين والولايات المتحده تطلق فيها
صواريخ لاغراق السفن فتخرج القاذفات
الصينيه بدوريه جويه مشتركه مع نظيراتها
الروسيه
الاستفزازات العسكريه توازيها اخرى سياسيه
ذروتها كانت العام الماضي عندما وصلت
رئيسه مجلس النواب الامريكي نانسي بلوسي
الى تايوان معتبرته بكين تدخلا في شانها
الداخلي
تريد الولايات المتحده من الصين عدم
التدخل في الشان الاوكراني وقف نشاطاتها
العسكريه والتجسسيه وتريد الصين من
الولايات المتحده عدم التدخل في شان
تايوان وان توقف نشاطها العسكري في دول
شرق اسيا تريد الولايات المتحده تنظيم
صناعه الذكاء الاصطناعي واطلاق معتقلين
ومنع تصنيع مواد مخدره وتريد الصين رقائق
الكترونيه
وبينما يراد وما يمكن تحقيقه طبق المنافسه
الشريفه بين قطبي الشرق والغرب هدفا قد
يكون بعيدا المنال
ينضم الينا من واشنطن مراسل العربيه بيار
غانم بعد خمس سنوات على زياره وزير خارجيه
امريكي الى بكين الى اي مدى يمكن ان نقول
حقق ما قال انه هدف الزياره وهو الحد من
سوء الفهم والحسابات الخاطئه
اعتقد ان والصينيين فعلوا امر واحد وهو
انهم جلسوا الى الطاوله ولكن هل وصلوا الى
اي نتيجه الجواب هو لا لو نظرنا الى مضمون
البيان الذي صدر عن وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه حول مضمون المحادثات بين وزيري
الخارجيه الامريكيه وصيني لوجدنا ان هناك
كلام كثير عن حسن النوايا ولكن ليس هناك
اي اتفاق واضح بين الطرفين على اي امر
بدءا من موضوع تايوان وصولا الى التمدد
العسكري الصيني في منطقه البحر الصين
ومنطقه المحيط الهادئ وصولا الى عدم وجود
التزام بعدم مساعده روسيا في حربها على
الاوكرانيين والى قضايا كثيره
اصداء هذه الزياره بالداخل الامريكي وسقف
التوقعات منها
هناك الكثير من التفاؤل بالنسبه
للامريكيين لكن هذا التفاؤل مشوب ايضا
بكثير من الشكوك ما شاهده الامريكيون من
الصينيين خلال الفتره الماضيه هو زياده
القدرات العسكريه والتكنولوجيه
والاقتصاديه والتجاريه من قبل الصين لكنهم
يخشون كثيرا تصاعد القوه الصينيه خصوصا ان
هذه القوه الصينيه لا تلتزم براي
الامريكيين بقواعد القانون الدولي وهذا
يشكل تهديد واضح بالنسبه للامريكيين لذلك
هم يسعون الى حد كبير جدا الى تطويق
تحركات الصين ووضع الاوروبيين الى جانب
الامريكيين هل الامريكيون واضحون في
بياناتهم وتصريحاتهم بشان اي قيادات رفيعه
اخرى يمكن ان يلتقيها
لاحقا بعد اللغات الذي صار حول اذا كان
سيلتقي الرئيس او لا او ايضا بشان اي
زيارات مستقبليه لمسؤولين صينيين بدورهم
الى الولايات المتحده الام ريكيه هل هناك
اي معلومات واضحه بهذا الشان
كثيرا اولا البيان الامريكي يشير الى ان
بلينكن سوف يبقى يوم التاسع عشر اي يوم غد
في الصين وهذا يشير بشكل واضح الى اجتماع
مع الرئيس الصيني الامر الاخر المهم هو
بالاضافه الى ان وزير خارجيه الصين من
الممكن ان يزور الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه القمه المقبله لدول المحيط
الهادئ سوف تنعقد في سان فرانسيسكو
الارجح ان الرئيس الصيني يريد ان يحضر هذه
القمه ويريد ان يبرد من حده الوضع قبل ان
ياتي الى هذه القمه عند الشاطئ الغربي
شكرا جزيلا لك اذا من واشنطن مراسل
العربيه بار غانم شكرا
[موسيقى]
الى تطورات الوضع في اوكرانيا الان حيث
كشف قائد القوات الجنوبيه بالجيش
الاوكراني لصحيفه فاينانشيل تايمز ان
القوات الاوكرانيه دمرت اثني عشر موقعا
لتخزين الذخيره الروسيه خلال 24 ساعه
واكدت الصحيفه ان الهجوم الاوكرانيه
المضاد حقق مكاسب متواضعه في الخطوط
الاماميه الروسيه شديده التحصين ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تركز في هذه المرحله المبكره
من الهجوم المضاد على تمهيد الارض امام
قواتها البريه وبدات تصاعد هجماتها
باستهداف مستودعات اسلحه وذخيره روسيه في
عمق الاراضي التي تسيطر عليها بحسب صحيفه
البريطانيه فان القوات الاوكرانيه تبحث عن
نقاط ضعف في الدفاعات الروسيه في المناطق
الجنوبيه الشرقيه
قال مسؤولون بريطانيون ان روسيا واوكرانيا
تعانيان سقوط اعداد كبيره من الجنود في
الوقت الذي تسعى به كياف لطرد قوات موسكو
من المناطق المسيطره عليها في المراحل
الاولى من هجومها المضاده وقد اوضح
مسؤولون عسكريون بريطانيون ان الخسائر
الروسيه ربما تكون في اعلى مستوياتها منذ
معركه بخموت في مارس الماضي ووفقا
للاستخبارات البريطانيه ايضا تركزت اعنف
المعارك في مقاطعه زابوريجيا جنوب شرق
اوكرانيا وحول بخموت والى الغرب في مقاطعه
دنيا شرق اوكرانيا
يذكر المشاهدون تذكرين راويه سؤالنا
المتكرر لضيوفنا هل تعلمت روسيا من
اخطائها لماذا لم تتعلم من اخطائها بعد
لدينا جواب الان او محاوله للاجابه من
الاعلام الغربي على الاقل روسيا بدات
تتعلم من اخطائها المكلفه عبر تغيير
تكتيكات ساحه المعركه في اوكرانيا بحسب
تقرير لنيويورك تايمز الصحيفه نقلت عن
جنود اوكرانيين قولهم ان القوات الروسيه
قامت بتحسين الانضباط والتنسيق والدعم
الجوي وانها اظهرت مستوى عاليا من
المهارات القتاليه ايضا بدا الروس باعداد
الكمائن للمركبات الاوكرانيه وروى جندي
اوكراني ان القوات الروسيه نصبت كمينا
لنقل جند مدرعه اوكرانيه وامطرتها بنيران
البنادق والمدفعيه ما جعل الجنود
الاوكرانيين محاصرين لساعات
اشارت الى ان القوات الروسيه حسنت
دفاعاتها ما جعلها مختلفه تماما عن الاشهر
الاولى للحرب عندما سيطرت روسيا على الارض
بقوتها الناريه المطلقه
كما انها لم تعد تندفع الى المناطق التي
يمكن ان تتضرر فيها بشكل كبير وغالبا ما
تستخدم طائرات المسيره للقصف وايضا لاغراض
الاستطلاع وباعتراف جنود اوكرانيين اثبتت
الخنادق والمخابئ الروسيه انها افضل بناء
من نظيراتها الاوكرانيه ما يجعل من الصعب
ان يتم اكتشافها بواسطه المسيرات رغم
التحسينات الا ان القدرات العسكريه
الروسيه تتفاوت على طول خط الجبهه الذي
يزيد عن الف كيلو متر في وقت يتم التركيز
على محاوله العثور على مراكز القياده
الميدانيه الاوكرانيه لتدميرها عن بعد
وتعطيل الاتصال بين الوحدات قدر الامكان
نيويورك تايمز نقلت عن مسؤولين امريكيين
قولهم ان التكتيكات الروسيه تحسنت بالفعل
الا انهم ارجعوا النجاح في بعض المعارك
مثل ضخمه الى زج قوات فاجنر السجناء في
القتال بغض النظر عن الخسائر في الارواح
بينهم ضربت الصحيفه على تغيير التكتيكات
الروسيه ببلده كريمينا شرق اوكرانيا التي
تحاول القوات الروسيه التوغل فيها من خلال
شن عمليات هجوميه صغيره وفرا من دون الدفع
بعدد كبير من القوات على كل لمتابعه ذلك
امريكيه من وجهه نظر ريتشرد ويدز مدير
مركز التحليل السياسي العسكري في معهد
ينضم الينا راويه اذا الان اهلا بك معنا
سيد ريتشارد يعني هل برايك هذه التقارير
الغربيه التي تتحدث عن تغيير روسي تكتيكي
بالاستراتيجيه العسكريه هل يعني ذلك يعني
حضرتك الطرف محايد انه ازدادت
الجهه الروسيه
بالتطور من ناحيه وضع الجنود من ناحيه
تدريبهم لانه عده تقارير غربيه وايضا
شهادات حيه عرضناها في برنامجنا لجنود روس
اسرى تم اسرهم تحدثوا انه يتم وضعهم
بالساحات القتال من دون اي تدريب هل تغيير
التكتيك يعني ازديادها تطورا ونوعيه
يبدو ان الامر يسير على هذا النحو فقد
خلنا انه خلال السنه الاولى كان اداء
القوات الروسيه دون التوقعات الى حد كبير
فقد قاموا بزياده تقدير حجم ما يمتلئ
يمتلكونه مقدرات واستخفوا بالقدرات
الاوكرانيه
وكانت هجمات مختلفه يتم شنها من مناطق
مختلفه دون اي تنسيق اما هذه السنه فمن
الواضح فانهم قد تعلموا من بعض هذه
الاخطاء
وباتوا في وطن قتالي افضل بفضل تنسيق
العمليات الدفاعيه هذه ليست مساله حديثه
فنحن راينا القوات العسكريه تبلي بلاء
سيئا في في حربها الاولى مع المانيا
ولكنها تحسنت مع مرور الوقت والولايات
المتحده ايضا عانت من تجاربه مماثله كنا
نتوقع هذا الامر لكن من الضروره ان نجري
نوعا من انواع المقارنه والتقييم نعم
الروس وقد تحسنوا لكن القوات الاوكرانيه
بالمقابل بات لديها اسلحه افضل
بالمقارنه مع السنه الاولى من الحرب ومن
المرجح ان نرى ان هذا سوف
ينجح وسوف يساعد القوات الاوكرانيه لتصبح
اكثر قوه في كيفيه استخدام الاسلحه
الاوروبيه بين ان الروس سوف يصبحون افضل
في وضعيه قتالهم مع الاوكرانيين الامر قد
يكونوا متساويا سؤالي لك كان عن موضوع
المقارنه هذه هو التي بدات حضرتك باجراءها
لذلك سابني على ما تفضلت به بسؤال يعني
متابعه
قلت بانه لديهم اسلحه افضل ولكن هل هذه
الجزئيه كافيه لمواجهه هذه التغيرات في
التكتيك الروسي ام ان اوكرانيا ستكون
بحاجه الى تغييرات اخرى بدورها ايضا غير
الاعتماد على الاسلحه الافضل التي بدات
تملكها الان
لعلها تفلح في ذلك القوات الاوكرانيه لا
تزال
تمتلك معنويات مرتفعه وكنا قد لاحظنا هذا
منذ بدء اندلاع القتال مع الروس لكن
القوات الروسيه لديها جنود وقوات اكت تفوق
بعددها من تلك الاوكرانيه الاجابه الصريحه
لا نعلم بكل امانه فالقوات الاوكرانيه
لم تقم
بارسال كافه قواتها بل ارسلت ما يصل الى
ربما من الربع منها واذا ما تبين لهم انه
مع استلامي هذه المدفعيات الغربيه
والدبابات فبعدها قد تبدي اهتماما
في المعركه القادمه لكن لا نعلم ما الذي
قد يحدث
وكيف سوف تسير الامور بيتي وباي اتجاه
النتائج التي حققتها عمليات الهجوم المضاد
للجيش الاوكراني هل ما حققته من نتائج
الغرب راض عنها خاصه انها استعاده مناطق
وقرى ولكنها ليست استراتيجيه سيد ريتشارد
هذا صحيح
ما اراه انه قد لا يجافي صواب بان العمليه
الهجوميه المضاده قد بدات للتو ولم تحقق
القوات الاوكرانيه الكثير من المكاسب
لكنها بدلت جهودا كبيره وما تزال تبدو
اشبه
بسبعينيات القرن الماضي عندما كانت هناك
مواجهه بين القوات الاسرائيليه والقوات
المصريه في حرب استنزاف لفهم قدراته كل
منهما وفي خلافا لعام
1973 عندما قامت مصر باتخاذ المبادره وشن
الهجوم اعتقد اننا سوف ننتقل الى هذه
المرحله عندما نرى اي من الطرفين سوف يكون
قدرا على اكتشاف نقاط ضعف الطرف الاخر
شكرا جزيلا لك استاذ ريتشار مدير مركز
تحليل السياسي العسكري في معهد هاتسون
قالت صحيفه ان هناك ادله تشير الى وقوف
روسيا خلف تدمير في منطقه تسيطر عليها
روسيا في اوكرانيا خلال الشهر الجاري
واشارت الصحيفه الى ان انفجار عبوه ناسفه
روسيه ادى الى تدميره
حقيقه تفجير سد كخوفك الاوكراني غرقت بين
تعدد الروايات مثل ما غرقت هذه المناطق
بالمياه نيويورك تايمز اشارت باصابع
الاتهام الى موسكو بالطلوع وراء الحادث
فاستد نهار نتيجه انفجار نفذه الجانب الذي
يسيطر عليه اي روسيا تقول الصحيفه
الامريكيه
التحقيق نقل عن مهندسين وخبراء قولهم ان
الفحص الكامل للسد بعد تصريف المياه منه
يمكن ان يحدد تسلسل الاحداث التي ادت الى
الدمار المهندسون اشاروا الى وجود ادله
حول انفجار عبوه ناسفه في ممر عبر القاعده
الخرسانيه للسد ما ادى الى تدميره التحقيق
استبعد فرضيه حدوث تاكل ناتج عن اندفاع
المياه عبر البوابات في حال كان تصميم
السد سيئا او كانت الخرسانه لا تستوفي
المعايير تحقيق صحيفه نيويورك تايمز يدعمه
فريق من الخبراء القانونيين الدوليين
الذين يس في تحقيق يجريه الادعاء
الاوكراني النتائج الاوليه المعلنه اشارت
الى ان الانهيار كان بسبب متفجرات زرعها
الروس على الارجح وبدرجه كبيره
الكرملين يتهم بتخريب السد الكهرومائي
بغرض قطع مصدر رئيسي للمياه عن شبه جزيره
القرم وصرف الانتباه عن الهجوم المضاد
فيما تقول اوكرانيا ان موسكو من فعل ذلك
وفي ظل الاتهامات المتبادله تتواصل
المعارك الضاريه على جبهات القتال
المختلفه بلال البجداني العربيه
[موسيقى]
تتابعون معنا في العربيه 360 ايضا هدوء
حذر في مختلف جبهات القتال في السودان في
اليوم الاول لهدنه 72 ساعه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلن مكتب الرئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو ان
اسرائيل ستعمل مع مصر والسلطه الفلسطينيه
على تطوير حقل غزه مارين للغاز الطبيعي
الواقع قباله ساحل القطاع غزه الذي تسيطر
عليه حركه حماس وشدد مكتبونه ان احراز
تقدم في المشروع سيكون بالتعاون مع
الاجهزه الامنيه ومن خلال محادثات مباشره
مع مصر وبالتنسيق مع السلطه الفلسطينيه
وفق قوله
اذا اسرائيل اعطت موافقتها المبدئيه على
تطوير حقل غاز قباله قطاع غزه واعلنت ان
الامر يستدعي تنسيقا امليا مع السلطه
الفلسطينيه ومصر الحقل هو غزه مارين يبعد
نحو 30 كيلومترا عن شواطئ قطاع غزه
وينتظر بدايه التنقيب بعد اكثر من عقدين
على اكتشافه في عام
1999 منحت السلطه الفلسطينيه رخصه للتنقيب
عن الغاز الطبيعي قباله سواحل غزه لمجموعه
بريتش غاز وشريكها شركه اتحاد المقاولين
التنقيب كشف عن حقل غزه مارين الذي يقع
على عمق
6303 امتار تحت سطح البحر ويقدر الاحتياطي
فيه باثنين وثلاثين مليار متر مكعب طبعا
السلطه الفلسطينيه اعطت بريتش غاز حق
التنقيب عن الغاز والنفط في المناطق
البحريه للسلطه وتسويق كميات من الغاز
والنفط في منطقه الرخصه لمده 25 عاما او
حتى 2027 فعده مرات تم تعديل الاتفاقيه
المنظمه للتنقيب في غزه مارينا وتغيير حصص
الاطراف المشاركه في التنقيب بعدما حصلت
السلطه الفلسطينيه في 2002 على موافقه
الشركاء لتعديل الاتفاقيه طبعا السلطه
الفلسطينيه سعت للتاكيد على حقوقها
السياديه على مواردها الطبيعيه عبر
انضمامها عام 2019
لمنتدى غاز الشرق المتوسط الذي دعت مصر
لتاسيسه وتسعى السلطه لاستخدام الغاز في
توليد الكهرباء وتقليل الاعتماد على
الخارج حيث تحصل على 92% من الطاقه
الكهربائيه من اسرائيل فيما النسبه
الباقيه من الاردن ومصادر الطاقه الشمسيه
ايضا يامل الفلسطينيون ان يكون غزه ماريين
مصدرا يدفع بالاقتصاد الفلسطيني وبابا ل
خلق العديد من فرص العمل حول هذا الموضوع
ينضم الينا من القاهره استاذ العلاقات
الدوليه في الجامعه الامريكيه الدكتور
طارق فهمي ومن حيفا ايضا المحلل السياسي
اهلا بكم معنا اهلا بكما ضيفينا ونبدا معك
لماذا يعني يجب علينا ان نقتنع بانه الان
اسرائيل بات لديها القدره على منح هذه
الموافقه ما الاهداف التي تسعى اليها في
هذا التوقيت
لا نعرف الاحداث بالضبط ولكن ما نعرفه ان
هناك انتظار طويل لان تعطي اسرائيل لضوء
الاخضر لتنكيب او لاستغلال
الغاز الذي موجود في عمق البحر وكما يبدو
هناك الان
جاهزيه او نضوج سياسي يمكن اسرائيل من هذا
الضوء الاخضر هذا المساء نشر بانه اسرائيل
قالت مصادر سياسيه رفيعه المستوى قالت ان
ان غزه
لا تستفيد من حقل الغاز وانما فقط السلطه
الفلسطينيه ومصر وجهات اخرى دوليه لها صله
في الموضوع ولكن انت ماذا تقصد بندوس
سياسي استاذن ثم ماذا كيف نفهم تعبير رئيس
الوزراء عندما يتحدث عن ضروره الحفاظ على
الاستقرار الامني او هذا سيساعد على
الحفاظ على الاستقرار الامني
طبعا بالنسبه للاستقرار الامني فهناك
تبعا حول الموارد الطبيعيه عده مصالح هذا
ما هو موجود في لبنان هذا ما هو موجود في
اسرائيل وحاليا في غزه اعتقد ان هناك
طبعا اهتمام فيما يجري في هذا الحقل
ولهذا السبب سيكون هناك مصلحه فلسطينيه
ايضا بعدم المساس في هذه الموارد الطبيعيه
او المنشات التي موجوده في عمق البحر
وبالنسبه للنضوج السياسي كما يبدو كما
يبدو هناك سيلا لاتصالات رفيعه المستوى
التي هي موجوده خارج المنطقه
الى الدكتور طارق سيد يواف دكتور طارق
يعني القلق الاسرائيلي الان من ان تستفيد
حركه حماس التي تسيطر على القطاع من
العائدات الماليه هذا هو القلق الاسرائيلي
الحقيقي
كيف سيتم الالتفاف على هذه النقطه تحديدا
واستفاده حركه ماء حماس من العوائد
الماديه وايضا ما دور مصر هنا
هو بالتاكيد طبعا في رسائل بليغه ومباشره
من رئيس الحكومه نفسه يعني وليس للمكونات
الائتلاف لنقل رسائل مباشره لكل الاطراف
حماس كقائمه تحفيزيه لها لمنع الاقدام على
الانخراط في اي مواجهه وانت تعلمي ان حماس
لم تشارك فيه المواجهات الاخيره فبالتالي
واضح ان هناك رساله بليغه الى حركه حماس
انكم اذا عدتم عدنا وستكون هناك قائمه
اخرى تحفيزيه لا علاقه لها بملف الغاز
لانه الموافقات سيدتي قديمه جديده تتجدد
مع كل فتره وبالتالي هي الرساله الاولى
الى حركه حماس الرساله الثانيه للسلطه
الفلسطينيه بضروره التجاوب ملف مقابل ملف
التنسيق الامني مقابل هذا الاتفاق المرتبط
بالغاز وبالتالي اسرائيل تريد ان تقول لي
محمود عباس ومن معهم من السلطه الفلسطينيه
انكم بطبيعه الحال شركاء وعليكم ان تنسقوا
التنسيق الامني الكامل مقابل ان تكون هناك
قبول بهذا الاتفاق هو ات فاق شارع بين مصر
كالشركه القابضه للغاز ايجاز في مصر
وصندوق الاستثمار الفلسطيني وسبق انه طرح
من عده اشهر واوقفته حركه حماس نتيجه
لتحفظات معينه الاجل
حركه حماس تحديدا هل ستقبل بالتنسيق مع
السلطه الفلسطينيه حول هذه النقطه وحول
العائدات الماديه
سيدتي ستقبل بطبيعه الحال لان هناك منافع
متبادله ما بين الطرفين ما بين اسرائيل
وحماس من جانب وبين حماس والسلطه
الفلسطينيه من جانب اخر وبالتالي اسرائيل
ورئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي يريد ان يقول
كما اشرت الى انه هناك فوائد لكل الاطراف
ايضا رساله الى مصر باعتبار ان مصر شريك
في ما يجري وانه وسيط وسيط مباشر فبالتالي
وان مصر هي التي سترعى الاتفاق الاتفاق
اصلا الاتفاق شارع ما بين الجانبين
الفلسطيني والمصري من خلال شركات مباشره
النقطه الاهم في تقدير ايضا هي التجاوب مع
الاداره الامريكيه لان الاداره الامريكيه
في حاله تجاذب مع الحكومه الاسرائيليه
والحكومه الاسرائيليه طبعا تريد ان تخاطب
بالولايات المتحده باننا نتجاوب مع ما
تطرحونه في ملفات معينه انت تعلمي ان
الاداره الامريكيه لم توجه الدعوه لزياره
نتنياهو اذا الى الولايات المتحده ودعت
الرئيس الاسرائيلي فبالتالي نتنياهو يريد
ان ينقل البليغه لكل الاطراف في هذا
التوقيت لكن لا توجد ضمانات لتنفيذ هذا
الاتفاق بمعنى ان مصر والسلطه الفلسطينيه
الان المطلوب منهما اعطاء هذه الضمانات
الكافيه لاسرائيل
استطاعوا ذلك بعد ختام هذه المفاوضات اعود
اليك هل تعتقد تحدثت قبل قليل عن نضوج
سياسي كما سميته
وتحدثت عن قوه خارج المنطقه او ماذا قصدت
بذلك ومن ثم هل نضوج سياسي يشمل بالضروره
حصول اسرائيل على ضمان بوقف استهدافها من
قبل الفصائل الفلسطينيه في غزه ان وافقت
تماما على هذا المشروع
بالنسبه للنضوج السياسي اعتقد انه لا يمكن
ان يقول رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي لانه
مستعد لاي اخضر لاستغلال الموارد الطبيعيه
الموجوده على شواطئ غزه بدون مقابل ما هو
هذا المقابل هل سيكون فقط محدود لتنسيق
امني استبعد ذلك اعتقد انه الرئيس الوزراء
معني بان يكون هناك تقارب مع جهات اخرى في
المنطقه التي تضمن وترعى ما يحدث الدور
المصري مهم جدا هنا لانه بدون دور نص
حماس وقطار غزه بشكل عام لا يستطيع ان
يكون جزء من هذه المعادله دور مصر هو طبعا
الاستفاده مما يجري ولكن ايضا
حقيبه العلاقات
والاتصالات مع طرف الفلسطيني في غزه وحركت
حماس تحديدا في يده لهذا السبب اعتقد اننا
نتحدث هنا عن صفقه التي هي اكبر فقط من
الشركاء التي ذكرناهم على راسهم ايضا
الولايات المتحده التي هي معانيه في مثل
هذه الخطوات تجاه الفلسطينيين وربما هذا
جزء من الجو الجديد في الولايات المتحده
التي هي معنيه في تفاهمات في المنطقه مثل
ما يجري في ايران
نكته انه هذا اليوم صدقت الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الاء خطوات اخرى تمكن البناء
وتوسيع المستوطنات فدائما نتنياهو من جهه
يقوم في خطوات ايجابيه جاء الفلسطينيين
بينما بنفس الوقت يرضي شركائه المستوطنين
في الحكومه هذا ما حصل اليوم دكتور طارق
يعني من سيعطي ضمانات على هذه الضمانات
الامنيه يعني
نحن نعلم بين فتره واخرى تندلع حرب بين
اسرائيل وحركه حماس وغيرها من الفصائل
الفلسطينيه بغزه بشكل عام بالقطع هل يمكن
تحييد هذا الاتفاق في المستقبل
هو بالتاكيد طبعا لكن يعني حماس لم تشارك
في المواجهات الاخيره كما تعلمي مع الجانب
الاسرائيلي وحركه الجهاد هي من قامت بهذا
وبالتالي انا اعتقد انه نتنياهو شخصيا
وليس مكونات لائتلاف والاحزاب المشاركه
معه يريد ان يقدم خطوه ايجابيه لحركه حماس
لدفعها للاستمرار في عدم استهدافه اسرائيل
وبالتالي هناك خطوه ذكيه من نتنياهو ان
يعلن هذا في هذا التوقيت لكن اسمحي لي ان
اقول لا احد يضمن اسرائيل وبالتالي موضوع
ان يكون هناك ضمانات تقدمها مصر او السلطه
الفلسطينيه لا احد يضمنها الضامن الوحيد
في هذا الاطار هو الولايات المتحده
الولايات المتحده دخلت على الخط بين
اسرائيل وبين لبنان ونجحت بمهاره في توقيع
اتفاق ترسيم الحدود البحريه بين الطرفين
اذا دخلت الولايات المتحده ايضا على الخطا
ستقوي مركز مصر والسلطه الفلسطينيه في هذا
التوقيت الولايات المتحده لديها قدرات
وامكانيات واشرت الى ان هناك تباين كبير
في الموقف الامريكي الاسرائيلي في ملفات
عده اعتقد الان ستكون هناك رسائل ايجابيه
في هذا الاطار استاذ شارين هل لديك رد على
ما تفضل به الدكتور لجهه عدم امكانيه ان
نضمان اسرائيل
بشكل طبيعه الحال كما قال
اسرائيل لا تضمن ان ترى في الفلسطيني او
العربي بانه حكى للغاز سيتم استغلاله بشكل
فوري ولكن نتحدث هنا عن تطوير مسالح
مشتركه وهكذا يجب ان يكون بانجيران اعتقد
انه لمصر دور مهم جدا ولولا ان تدخل مصر
على الخط لا ما كنا نرى مثل هذه صفقه الان
لانه ليس في قدره اسرائيل وسلطه
الفلسطينيه والولايات المتحده لوحدهم
لوحدها ان تصل الى مثل هذه النتائج بدون
الوساطه المصريه المصريه هم من ياخذوا على
عاتقهم ملف الاتصالات مع جانب الفلسطيني
في غزه حماس والمنظمات الاخرى وفي ظل ما
يحدث هناك امكانيه للوصول الى نوع من
التعاون غير المباشر بين كل هذه الاطراف
التي ذكرناها لصالح الشعوب هذا
مشروع ايجابي جدا لمصلحه كل من هو موجود
في المنطقه شكرا لكما من حيث المحلل
السياسي من القاهره استاذ العلاقات
الدوليه في الجامعه الامريكيه دكتور طارق
فهمي تحياتنا شكرا لكما
[موسيقى]
في السودان قال وزير الحكم الاتحادي محمد
صالح ان الاوضاع الامنيه مستتبه في 15
ولايه من اصل ثماني عشره ولايه في البلاد
مشيرا الى ان العاصمه الخرطوميه الاكثر
تضررا من الحرب فيما شاهدت نفس العاصمه
العاصمه الخرطوم هدوءا
مع توقف دوري المدافعي واصوات الرصاص
وتحليق الطائرات الحربيه بعد اعلان
السعوديه والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
التوصل لهدنه جديده لمده ثلاثه ايام
وفي مقابله خاصه مع العربيه قال مالك
عقارنه رئيس مجلس السياده السودانيه ان
الوضع في دارفور كارثي كما هو الحال
بالخرطوم مشيرا الى ان القوات التي تقاتل
هناك ترتدي ملابس الدعم السريعه
ان نتحدث عن اقتتال اهلي لكن هنالك اقتتال
في دارفور والحديث عنه يعني فيه نوع من
الازدواجيه والحديث انه يعني مرات يتجاوز
الواقعيه ومرات الاتهامات هنا هنالك لكن
لا نقدر لا نستطيع ان نجزم ان الوظيفه في
دارفور القتال في دارفور هو قتال
قتال اهلي بكلياته لكن هنالك قتال هنالك
وضع كارثه في دارفور وبالذات في منطقه
الجنينه والمناطق الاخرى لا نستطيع
التوصيل
بعد القبض على تسعه مصريين من قبل السلطات
اليونانيه بتهمه لتجار في البشر نشدت اسر
الموقوفين السلطات المصريه تدخل عاجلا من
اجل اطلاق سراح الموقوفين مؤكدين ان
ابنائهم سافروا كمهاجرين وليس كمهربين
العربيه زارت اسر بعض الموقوفين في محافظه
المنوفيه
وجهت السلطات اليونانيه تهمه الى تسعه من
المصريين بتيسير الهجره غير المشروعه
والشروع في القتل وغيرها من الاتهامات
ثلاثه من هؤلاء من قريه البتانون في
محافظه المنوفيه زرنا منازلهم وتفاجئنا
بقصه مختلفه مفادها ان هؤلاء انفسهم كانوا
من المهاجرين غير القانونيين وليسوا من
المهربين
عماد السيد يروي لنا قصه ابنه اتصل عليه
وقالوا لابنك في المستشفى اهوت ما تخافش
عليه افاجئ بعد يومين يتصل علي نفس الولد
ويقول له ده خد ابنك علشان يحاكموه ولا هم
بيحطوا رزيه في قفل غلابه يعني دوله بتخلص
من دوله عشان يطلعوا ابرياء يشوفوا لنا
راضيه كمان تانيه لعيالنا ولا كانوا
عاوزين العشره اللي صاحيين يموتوا الاخرين
اشرف هو الاخر يحكي لنا قصه شقيقه سيد
احمد الذي سافر الى ليبيا منذ شهرين ومكث
فيها حتى موعد السفر اشرف استدان لشقيقه
ثمن الرحله المقدر باربعه الاف وخمسمائه
دولار على حد قوله طالع ياكل عيش لمهرب
ولا بيتعامل مع المهربين ولا بيتعامل مع
حد راكب زيه مهاجر زي الناس المهاجره زيه
زيها حد زي السوري زي المصري زي اي حد
وانا بنشد رئيس الجمهوريه وبلاش السفاره
المصريه تشوف لنا حل في الموضوع ده ومش
هيبقى معي فلوس اجيب لهم حامي اجيب لهم
حامي منين انا دلوقتي عايزين محمد حقوق
الانسان يروح له ويشوفناه الوضع ده ده
مظلوم وصاحب عيال حماته سيد تبكي مصير زوج
ابنتها وتدعو له بالنجاه من هذه التهمه
[موسيقى]
ايضا كيف يؤثر الذكاء الاصطناعي في الحروب
الحديثه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اذا اخبار عاجله راويه
صحيحه مرتبطه بهنتر بايدن
عن وثائق سريه وثائق بشان علاقه مشبوهه
لبعض ونجله باوكرانيا تعود لعام 2015 اذا
فوكس نيوز تقول ان بايدن ضغط على اوكرانيا
عام 2015 لاقاله مدعي كان يحقق بقضيه تخص
نجله اخر الاخبار العاجله تشير ايضا راويه
وفقا لوثائق فوكس نيوز الجديده الاخبار
الجديده تتحدث عن المدعي العام ايضا اذا
ايضا بايدن حسب وثائق فوكس نيوز هدد بقطع
مليار دولار من المساعدات ليكياف عام 2015
ان لم تقل المدعي العامه الذي طلب بايدن
باقالته كان يحقق بقضيه شركه عمل بها نجله
هنتر كانت قضيه ناقشناها كثيرا في السابق
ولكنها طويت الان تفتح
فصولا مجددا وعده دعاوى قضائيه ايضا
يواجهها
قد تكون مهدده له بالسجن قبل سباق
الانتخابات الرئاسيه لعام 2024 وتزداد
مخاوف الديمقراطيين من تاثير ذلك على حمله
والده الانتخابيه
مع اقتراب سباق الانتخابات الامريكيه 2024
هنتر بايدن نجل الرئيس الامريكي قد يكون
مهددا بالسجن فقد كان هو وطليقته لندن
روبرتس في قاعه محكمه اركانسس لتقديم
افادته بشان دعوى قضائيه طلب خلالها تقليل
نفقه ابنته ومنعها من اخذ اسمه الاخير
القاضي كان امر هنتر بايدن في مارس 2020
بدفع اموال لاعاله الطفل المولود عام 2018
لكن هانتر طلب في سبتمبر 2022
تخفيض المبلغ من عشرين الف دولار بسبب
دخله المتغير مما ادى الى ارجاء موعد
المحاكمه وفقا لصحيفه usa today اسم
الطفله نقطه خلاف اساسيه حيث تريد والدتها
ان تكون مرتبطه باسم عائله بايدن بسبب
شهره العائله السياسيه ونجاحيها التجاريه
لكن هانتر
يعارض ذلك بسبب الحرب السياسيه التي يمكن
ان تواجهها هذه القضيه هي مجرد احد
التحديات القانونيه التي تواجه هانتر
بايدن الذي اصبح مصدر قلق للديمقراطيين في
الكونجرس خشيه تاثيره على الرئيس جو بايدن
وحملته الانتخابيه
اما الجمهوريون فيحققون في مجلس النواب
فيما اذا كان هنتر بايدن قد كوفي بتاثيره
على الاداره الامريكيه من خلال صفقات
تجاريه مربحه او مبيعات فنيه وهي مزاعم
نفاهه هانتر والبيت الابيض
[موسيقى]
الحديث عن الذكاء الاصطناعي غالبا ما
يتطرق الى تاثيره على الوظائف التي قد تحل
فيها الروبوتات محل البشر او حتى الحديث
عن التاثير على التعليم وخلافه لكن كيف من
الممكن ان يؤثر الذكاء الاصطناعي على حروب
المستقبل
القوه الكبرى سارعت لاستغلال هذه التقنيه
فالولايات المتحده بدات اختبار برامج ذكاء
اصطناعي لقياده طائرات اف 16 معدله بينما
تعمل روسيا على تجربه مركبات مدرعه تشبه
الدبابات وتكون اليه ومسيره بالكامل
التطورات الحاليه المعلن منها والسري لا
تشير الى قرب استخدام انظمه عسكريه اليه
بالكامل الا انها ستكون جزءا من حروب
المستقبل خبراء قالوا ان السعي الحديث
لاختبار التقنيات الجديده اكبر من جهود
تقييم اخطار التقنيه وحدود استخدامها
البرمجيات العامله بالذكاء الاصطناعي
ستؤدي لتقليص وقت اتخاذ القرارات الى
دقائق ربما مع وجود لا غنى عنه للعنصر
البشري في عمليه اتخاذ القرار لكن يبقى
الهاجس الاكبر للمتابعين هو وقوع هذه
التقنيه بايد قد تسمح للالات بحريه عمل
اكبر او قد تستخدمها بشكل خاطئ
[موسيقى]
نشرت مقاطع مصوره جديده لاعضاء من حزب
المحافظين في تجمع ينتهك قيود تباعد
الاجتماعي خلال احتفال يعود الى ديسمبر
2020 وذلك في مقر حمله حزب المحافظين في
لندن خلال فتره اغلاقات كورونا
في ديسمبر من عام 2020 وفي مقر حزب
المحافظين هذا احتفل موظفون في تجمع خالف
كل قواعد التباعد الاجتماعي التي كان من
المفترض على البريطانيين والمقيمين
الالتزام بها ففي الوقت الذي يرغب العالم
بتجاوز فتره كورونا بريطانيا لا زالت تنبش
في الماضي وتصفي حسابات منتهيكي قيود
كورونا
مقاطع مصوره جديده تعيد الزخم لفضائح
البارتي غيت وانتهاكات اعضاء الحزب
المحافظين السافره في فتره اغلاقات كورونا
اكثر من 20 موظفا ظهروا في مقاطع يرقصون
ويحتفلون بينهم اشخاص كرموا من قبل بورج
جونسون الاستياء المتكرر والمستمر من
انتهاكات المحافظين لقيود كورونا يعود الى
شعور الناس بالظلم بسبب منعهم من الاختلاط
والوجود مع افراد عائلتهم الذين قضى
الكثير منهم في المستشفيات وحدهم بالاضافه
الى خيبه امل من حكومه وضعت قوانين لم
تلتزم بها ورئيس حكومه كرم موظفين لم
يحترموا قيودا من المفترض انها تطبق على
الجميع
[موسيقى]
اعتقد ان الامر خرج عن السيطره تماما
واريد ان اعتذر للجميع الذين ينظرون الى
هذه الصوره ويرون اشخاصا ينتهكون القواعد
الموضوعه اصلا لحمايتنا جميعا
ورغم ان الشرطه تحققت في الاحتفال في وقت
سابق لكن من المتوقع ان تلقي المقاطع
المصوره الجديده ضوءا جديدا على القضيه
ومجريات التحقيق فيها استثنى المحافظون
انفسهم من القواعد وحاولوا اخفاء ادله لا
زال تلاحق رئيس الحكومه الاسبق برج جونسون
تزامنا مع تصويت يجري في مجلس العموم غدا
قد يجرب جونسون من حقه في الدخول الى
البرلمان كنائب صادق من لندن عروب عبد
الحق العربيه
[موسيقى]
اعلنت المملكه العليا السعوديه ان غدا
الاثنين هو اول ايام شهر ذي الحجه على ان
تكون الوقفه في عرفه يوم الثلاثاء السابع
والعشرين من يونيو واعلنت المحكمه العليا
السعوديه اذن يا طاهر انه مراسل العربيه
ايضا نقل عنها برصد هلال شهر ذو الحجه في
مراصد تمير وسدير والمجمعه في السعوديه
ليكون غدا الاول من شهر ليكون يوم غد
الاول من شهر ذي الحجه على ان يكون اول
ايام عيد الاضحى المبارك الاربعاء الثامن
والعشرين من يونيو
[موسيقى]
كل عام وانت بخير والجميع بخير ان شاء
الله الرابع من ذي الحجه اخر الايام
المحدده لوصول حجاج الخارج الى مكه
المكرمه خلال الايام الماضيه نقل اكثر من
نصف
مليون قدمنا من المدينه المنوره بعد زياره
المسجد النبوي مليونا حاج من خارج
السعوديه وقرابه 300 الف حاج من الداخل هم
الاعداد المحدده لاداء الحج هذا العام
وفي شان مرتبط بالحج لا يزال نشاط بيع
الهدايا التذكاريه في مكه يواجهوا تحديات
تحول بينه وبين تصنيع منتجاته محليا لكون
معظم منتجات هدايا الحجاج تستورد من
الخارج الزميل نواف عزيز يرصد اوضاع اسواق
الهدايا في مكه
مئات المتاجر في اسواق مكه المكرمه تسجل
ارتفاعا هائلا في مبيعات الهدايا
التذكاريه في مواسم الحج
وعلى الرغم من وفره الهدايا في الاسواق
الا انها قد لا تلبي طموحات البعض ممن
يبحثون عن منتجات ترتبط بروحانيه العاصمه
المقدسه
ومكانتها في نفوسهم المعدن النمو انا ما
اقول ان هو سيء بالعكس معدل النمو جيد لكن
انت ذكرت نقطه مهمه انه احنا لازم نعتمد
اكثر على المنتج السعودي يمكن اليوم تصنيع
الهدايا في خارج المملكه لكن وقعها واثرها
حيكون اكبر لما صناعه داخل السعوديه
التوجهات حيال دعم صناعه الهدايا
التذكاريه محليا جاده لكنها بطيئه ويبدو
ان هناك معوقات تحول دون الاستثمار في
القطاع مثل سعر التكلفه
هذا المصنع في مكه يعد من اولى المصانع
السعوديه التي تنتج هدايا بافكار جديده
مثل تصنيع مجسم لحد الحرم ومفتاح الكعبه
وقفلها فيما ينتظر القائمون عليه فرصا
داعمه لاستمرار مشروعهم النوعي فاصراحه
الان المصانع السعوديه قادره بشكل كبير
جدا على انها تغطي احتياجات السوق يعني
المتوقف الان الموضوع على التوجيه
شهد شهر ابري للماضي اطلاق منتدى منافع
برعايه حكوميه لدعم الفرص الاستثماريه في
مكه والمدينه ورفع الناتج المحلي في
المدينه المقدستين ولم يقدم المنتدى حتى
الان برامج تركز على جذب استثمارات في
تصنيع الهدايا التذكاريه التي يبلغ حجم
سوقها العشره مليارات ريال وفقا لتقديرات
الخبراء
من مكه المكرمه نواف عزيز العربيه
[موسيقى]
تصريح اليوم في العربيه 360 رجاء اعطوا
بعضا كلمه السر كي يغرد بنفسه تلك
التغريده للمليار دار الامريكي الان ماسك
وذلك في تلميح الى ان من يدير حساب الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن على تويتر لا يفقه شيئا
جاءت دعوه ماسك بعد ان نشر بايدن تغريده
تقول ان الوقت قد حان كي يبدا فاحش الثراء
بدفع ضرائبهم
في تغريده اخرى ان عوده بايدن ستضر فقط في
الفئات ذات الدخل المنخفض والمتوسط
سوره اليوم في العربيه 360 من العراق لوحه
حجريه مسماريه عمرها 2800 عام احد الاثار
المنهوبه من العراق الزاخري بالمواقع
الاثريه لكنها اليوم عادت الى موطنها
الاصلي اعدتها روما لبغداد خلال زياره
الرئيس العراقي لايطاليا قبل ايام
اللوحات تحمل شعره الملك الاشوري شلنصر
الثالث الذي حكم منطقه نمرود عامه 850 قبل
الميلاد ظروف فصولها الى ايطاليا لا تزال
مجهوله راوياك غيرها من التحف العراقيه
الموجوده في عواصم غربيه عده
ننهي العربيه 360 ولكن اخبار الساعه لا
تنقطع مستمره مع الزميل صهيب شراير واخبار
الساعه
مساء النور راويه وطاهر بالفعل جولتنا
الاخباريه السريعه الشامله والمتنوعه
اخبار الساعه بعد قليل في الصداره في
السودان والتحذيرات من وضع كارثي في
دارفور الحرب في اوكرانيا يبدو ان الهجوم
المضاد لم يؤتي بالنتائج التي كانت
تتوقعها اوكرانيا كذلك زياره بلنكن الى
الصين يبدو انها لم تحقق اختراقا كبيرا في
العلاقات الصينيه الامريكيه وكذلك تسريع
الاستيطان في الضفه الغربيه اليك تفضل
شكرا لكما
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات